et bien bonjour à tous on est en direct
sur brut pour vous parler de la gestion
des masques par l'état avec gérard davet
et fabrice lhomme qui sont grand
reporter au monde alors bonjour à vous
messieurs bonjour bonjour on va essayer
de justement de rentrer dans cette
enquête parce que c'est une enquête en
cinq parties que vous avez dévoilé dans
les colonnes du journal le monde il ya
de cela quelques jours
mais tout d'abord peut-être cette
première question qu'est ce qui vous a
poussé à aller enquêter justement sur
cette gestion des masques
on va dire assez chaotique il ya
plusieurs raisons je pense que la
première c'est qu'on est dans un dans un
journal qui s'est mobilisée entièrement
dès le début de la crise du duc au vide
et gérard et moi on a beau être plutôt
est estampillé enquêteurs politique ou
ou spécialisés dans les affaires
politico-financières les affaires de
corruption on s'est dit on peut pas
rester à l'écart
donc il fallait qu'on mette la main à la
pâte aussi en apportant on va dire notre
expertise d'enquêteurs entre guillemets
et puis il ya eu peut-être un autre
aspect aussi c'est que souvent on a
l'impression de faire des enquêtes qui
peut être ne parle pas directement aux
gens quand on fait des affaires de
fraude fiscale internationale par
exemple est ce que chacun peut se
reconnaître
pas forcément et là moi je sais que j'ai
pensé quand j'ai parlé de ce sujet à ma
fille aînée natacha et elle m'a dit mais
papa tu va peut-être pouvoir faire enfin
un sujet qui intéresse tout le monde
ou plutôt plus exactement qui intéresse
chacun d'entre nous et c'est vrai que
samassa ben ça m'a fait tilt suis pas ce
qu'il en est pour toi gérard mais moi ça
a été un déclencheur aussi même principe
un c'est que c'est pareil j'ai aussi
parlé à ma fille lisa va faire un de
deux filles qui qui qui en général pour
tendre un peu de mal à s'intéresser aux
aspects politico financier mais là elle
a trouvé ça tout à fait intéressant le
côté masque mais le côté en plus de
masques côté gestion sanitaire et le
deuxième trou qui était vraiment très
important aussi pourquoi est ce qu'on
s'est lancé là dessus c'est parce que
tout simplement on a effectivement un
background politique avec fabrice de
plus tôt qu on fait ça on connaît
beaucoup de gens dans le domaine
politique on a beaucoup moins car les
adresses et on s'est dit qu'il était
peut-être intéressant de revenir sur
cette crise sanitaire et sur la gestion
sanitaire de la france à travers le
nombre de le nombre de contacts qu'on
avait qu'il pouvait nous aider justement
à comprendre à mieux comprendre il ya
digérer ce qui avait pu se passer
donc on s'est dit qu'on pouvait avoir
une plus value là dessus alors cette
enquête justement elle est en cinq
parties ça commence en 2005 le premier
titre justement c'est le temps de
l'armement ça
iteere donc on est vraiment quinze ans
auparavant on est loin de cette période
justement en dépit de coronavirus mais
non résultats justement de préparation
ces questions sont plutôt évoquée
régulièrement
oui c'est à dire qu'il faut remonter à
peu près aux années on va dire au début
des années 2000 pour faire vraiment les
histoires très précisément avec des
nouvelles menaces qui apparaissent il ya
les menaces terroristes
comme tout le monde et bien sûr en tête
le 11 septembre 2001 et d'autres
attentats qui était prévu ou du moins
redoute et notamment des attentats
bactériologiques et puis il ya aussi des
premières pandémie importantes qui vont
arriver notamment d'asie par exemple
strass à partir de 2003 notamment et
tous toutes ces nouvelles menaces vont
amener les responsables publics en
france en tous les cas avoir une
réflexion sur le fait savoir si on était
assez protégé ou pas il va y avoir deux
ou trois personnes importantes au niveau
politique philippe douste-blazy
notamment qui va être ministre de la
santé
entre 2003 et 2005 puis ensuite son
successeur xavier bertrand et ses deux
ministres chacun à sa façon vont estimer
que non la france n'est pas suffisamment
armé et va commencer on va entrer dans
une phase qui va être celle qui qui font
qu'on appelle celle de l'armement où on
va commencer à se doter de moyens pour
se protéger au cas où faut bien
comprendre que c'est au cas où c'est à
dire qu'à l'époque les dangers sont
plutôt abstrait la france n'est pas
frappé par des menaces particulières
hormis la canicule c'est assez
spécifique mais la canicule 2003 qui qui
qui est un peu inquiète tout le monde
mais malgré tout on n'est pas encore
submergés par des menaces de pandémie
internationale qui aurait des
conséquences comme celle d'aujourd'hui
mais en tous les cas on se prépare et on
vaque donc commencé à entreposer des
masques des vaccins mais surtout des
basques donc ça c'est 2005 2007
ensuite il ya ce qu'on appelle à partir
de 2007 le le principe de précaution
alors on et 2007 2010 justement cette
période où il va y avoir notamment la
grippe h1n1 dont coup là justement il ya
ce principe de prendre beaucoup de
masques etc des stocks qui à l'époque
avait d'ailleurs été aussi critiquée par
rapport aux dépenses
donc là on est sur une autre étape c'est
la gestion d'une crise sanitaire leur
qui fort heureusement nous fera pas tout
autant que celle du corps d'un virus
parce qu'on dénombre seulement quelques
centaines ans étaient 450 442 victimes
en l'espace de quelques mois donc bien
loin des près
de 28000 qu'on a aujourd'hui en france
déclaré dans les hôpitaux ne faisait pas
de sens les décès en ville donc à cette
époque là il ya l'idée inverse
aujourd'hui quelque part oui c'est
roselyne bachelot qui est au pouvoir en
tout cas qui est ministre de la santé et
ce qui est très intéressant c'est comme
au monde on a des lecteurs qui sont
extrêmement exigeants
on a souvent employé le terme de
principe de précaution et on a une
lectrice mes écrits ya pas très
longtemps et qu'il ait dit qu'il fallait
parler des principes de prévention
donc c'est intéressant tard qu'à
l'époque effectivement il y avait un
principe de prévention qui s'imposaient
et qui était que qui avait été mis en
place dans ce paradis et bertrand qui
avait bien compris le problème qui avait
cet accroc n'était pas équipé du tout et
qui avait mis en place tout un stock
il y avait créé une structure qui
s'appelle l'eprus établissement de
préparation et de réponse aux urgences
sanitaires et qui étaient chargés de
gérer manière quasi militaire des stocks
nombreux de vaccins 2 / blues et de
masques et donc on était à plus d'un
milliard et nine masque à l'époque déjà
et en fait quand la grippe h1n1 arrive
là on a la preuve de vaccins donc gros
si mme bachelot a acheté 94 millions de
doses de vaccin à des prix extrêmement
élevé ça c'est vrai et cette campagne de
vaccination va être extrêmement décrié
puisque les médecins libéraux ne sont
pas associés et qu en outre peu français
finalement ils vont se faire vacciner il
y aura effectivement relativement peu de
17 et donc du coup derrière le
contrecoup habituel il va y avoir des
enquêtes de la cour des comptes
des enquêtes de sénateur et même des
enquêtes pénales qui vont faire que le
pouvoir politique va se dire waouh
on en a fait trop on a dépensé beaucoup
d'argent pour une crise qui s'est révélé
assez décevante entre guillemets
finalement peut-être qu on a fait trop
et peut-être que le risque en fin le jeu
n'en vaut pas le risque entre guillemets
et que donc on a on a on a été trop loin
dans la principe de prévention et c'est
là que la bascule se perd et c'est là
que le danger s'installe et il va ya
voir si je peux préciser sur ce point
une des critiques de mauvaise foi qui
vont être faites contre on va dire là la
doctrine bachelot notamment le fait
qu'on va mettre en rapport et sailor des
rapports parlementaires même un rapport
de la cour des comptes on va mettre en
rapport les dépenses qui ont été
effectués qui sont énormes
il n'y a pas de doute un alors suivant
les évaluations n'est 600 millions
d'euros un sénateur parlera je crois de
1 milliard de deux d'argent public
aurait été dépensé et on met ça en
rapport avec le nombre de victimes qui
effectivement être quelques centaines
donc évidemment le citoyen
un moyen et holland n'da se dit mais
enfin c c'est ce qu'on a fait on a
dépensé autant d'autant d'argent pour
finalement une grippette comme on monte
appuie encore redit récemment au début
du coc vide oui mais sauf qu on oublie
de dire que les vaccins ils n'ont pas
été jeté tous à la poubelle il ya près
de six millions de français qui sont
vaccinées ce qui veut dire donc si ces
six millions de personnes et sans doute
les plus fragiles n'avaient pas été
vaccinés
il y aura peut-être pas eu 300 400 morts
il y aurait peut-être eu 3000 ou trente
mille morts on ne le saura jamais mais
donc c'est un peu facile de dire à bien
oui mais on en a fait trop regarder la
preuve il n'y a pas beaucoup de morts
mais c'est peut-être à faire ce qu'il
faut dire c'est peut-être parce qu'on en
a fait peut-être pas trop mais beaucoup
qui a eu peu de morts mais ça à l'époque
c'est pas du tout audible ce que va
retenir l'opinion publique parce que la
classe politique va pas se retourner
contre bachelot c'est ses délires en
tout ce qu'elle a fait tout ça pour
finalement un petit virus qui qui qui
nécessitait pas cet armement ce
surarmement quelque sorte à l'essai
vaccin il ya ces masques à ce moment là
on a une
combien de masse que finalement ils se
basent il est au plus fort de la crise
on sera à 2 milliards 2 de mad milliard
deux cents millions de masques à mettre
en rapport avec les 117 millions qu'on
avait en février 2020 dont on maintient
à 2 milliards 200 millions de masques
qu'ils étaient des masques censé être en
bon état les dunes et deuxièmement
distribué gratuitement à la population
donc la population n'aurait pas eu
besoin de se ruer dans les pharmacies
des dépenses et 85 cents 84 centimes
d'euro par masque donc là on était
vraiment bien équipé mais parce que la
différence alors on y verra sur la
période 2017 2020 c'est que aujourd'hui
le coût de production des masques
beaucoup plus cher parce qu'il ya
l'offre et la demande et on achète des
masques beaucoup plus cher qu'on les en
a acheté il ya quelques mois avant cette
crise sanitaire et des stocks qui ont
été constitués en dehors de crise de
grandeur de plein de crise sanitaire
mais tout à fait le problème il est
double s'il voulait c'est d'abord
effectivement le coût du masque si vous
l'achetez en période de crise
sa triple a en gros c'est ça on nous on
a contacté le premier fabricant
historique de masques en france ô
l'entreprise qui est située dans l'est
dans les côtes d'armor et qu'ils savent
être peintes elle qui nous a dit que
c'était police elle ça lui coûtait 35
centimes
et aujourd'hui c'est 95 centimes et je
ne parle même pas des prix à
l'importation quand on veut avec les
américains auprès des chinois
ça c'est la première chose donc on l'est
on les fabrique et aujourd'hui les
acheter surtout aujourd'hui coûte
beaucoup
plus cher que si on les avait conservés
et continuer d fabriquer nous-mêmes et
deuxième point qui est hyper important
gérard l'a dit mais j'insiste parce que
personne n'en parle alors que c'est un
sujet à mon défi hyper important c'est
que il était prévu grâce à ses stocks
colossaux que les masques en cas de
pandémie serait mis à la disposition des
citoyens gratuitement gratuitement or
aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout ce qui se
passe il ya certes la bonne volonté de
certains élus régionaux qui aussi parce
qu'ils sont des êtres arrière pensées
électorales mais ils ont droit aussi
d'avoir des bonnes idées vont faire des
distributions gratuites dans le métro ou
auprès de leurs administrés mais l'état
en tant que tel aujourd'hui n'est pas
capable de donner à ses concitoyens des
masses parce qu'il les a il les a
dilapidé tout simplement
et donc on exige des français qu'ils
aillent les acheter or pour des petits
budgets c'est un problème et ça pose un
problème de santé publique parce qu'on
ne peut pas exclure que des gens
s'interdisent j'allais dire d'acheter
des masques
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens ou
même j'allais dire par principe parce
que ça existe mais je suis quand même je
sais c'est cher je vais pas me payer un
euro pour un beauty ce même pas de tissu
de plastique que je vais que j'ai jeté
cinq minutes après donc j'ai pas envie
de le faire et ça pose un problème
financier mais aussi de santé publique
cette cette impéritie de l'état qui est
qui qui est ce qui est celle et qu'on
constate aujourd'hui et qui est choquant
au regard de ce qu'on avait prévu il ya
dix ans où on avait un système qui était
qui était organisée pour répondre à une
pandémie comme celle là dans la
chronologie des faits justement on
évoquait les deux mineurs 2 comment on
arrive à cette situation aujourd'hui où
justement cette pénurie
et encore cette chronologie donc après
donc le h1n1 finalement ça n'arrive pas
trop en feront donc ces masques
finalement ne sont pas vraiment utilisé
il reste en stock
qu'est ce qui se passe ensuite durant
les années suivantes
alors il ya une première chose qui est
importante à noter c'est que vous savez
en france on est quand même une réplique
d'experts dont il y avait beaucoup
d'experts qui ont été sollicités pour
rendre des rapports ces rapports
on les a tous consulter avec fabrice ans
il ya des rapports qui date de 2005 qui
fleurissent à exhumer des rapports
confidentiels qui est essentiel reste et
qui le font et c'est très longtemps et
peut-être trop longtemps d'ailleurs
et en le sortant on a bien vu que dès
2005 par exemple avec des experts
assermentés qui disait les masques sont
indispensables en cas d'épidémie voilà
ça c'était clair et précis je parle des
masques chirurgicaux pas des masques
ffp2 vous savez les bec de canard
c'étaient les masques chirurgicaux donc
à destination de la population c'était
indispensable
donc il ya tous ces rapports qui
arrivent les uns après les autres 2005
2009 2011 2019 il ya plein de rapports
qui vont être rendues au moins une
dizaine durant ces années là qui conclut
tous au fait que les masses sont
indispensables ils disent aussi qu'il
faut un milliard de masques
c'est le chiffre de base un milliard de
masques pour faire face à une pandémie
tout le monde s'accorde là dessus après
il ya eu une dont les années 2011 et
ensuite 2012 2013
une évolution de la doctrine qui est
très importante parce que là aussi elle
va poser des problèmes c'est que
concrètement l'état devrait garder à sa
charge les masques chirurgicaux donc un
stock de masques chirurgicaux
donc ces masques classique qui filtre
entre 40 et 60% des parts études c'est
déjà très efficace en cas de pandémie et
les masques ffp2 et bien c'était aux
établissements en région c'est à dire
les hôpitaux les ehpad les cas c'était à
eux de les acheter sur le propre budget
pour les stocker qu'est ce qui s'est
passé avec cette décision c'est d'un
côté l'état a conservé la gestion des
matches chirurgicaux en dix ans il y en
a marre c'est mal ça sert à rien
finalement ça coûte cher on va qu'est ce
qu'on va en faire et on fabrique on
expliquera ce qui s'est passé ensuite
et les masques ffp2 et ben très
concrètement les établissements région
ils ont eu autre chose à faire que
d'acheter des masques parce que il avait
d'énormes problèmes de budget d'énormes
problèmes de budget et donc du coup il
n'allait pas dépenser de l'argent dans
l'achat de masques qui devait servir de
manière hypothétique donc là la doctrine
a fait qu' il ya eu effectivement une
scission et à une scission importante
dans la gestion des masques dont il faut
préciser avec doctrine elle a été on va
dire élaboré en 2011 donc à l'époque
c'est encore xavier mère fond qui est
qui et mini de la santé et elle a été
officialisée en 2013 alors que c'est
marisol touraine et donc on a changé de
quinquennat on est passé de sarkozy
hollande qui est aux manettes c'est
important de le préciser parce que ça
montre bien que les grilles de lecture
purement politico politiciennes ne
fonctionne pas forcément et ça met en
lumière par contre un phénomène que nous
on a observé à travers cette enquête et
qui est pas forcément très rassurant
c'est que les politiques se sont un peu
des saisies ou ont été dessaisis tu sais
ces questions santé publique au profit
des hauts fonctionnaires notamment ceux
qui oeuvrent au sein du secrétariat
général de la défense et de la sécurité
nationale pardon c'est un peu mon bien
et là l'acronyme est encore pire sgdsn
mais sauf que c'est un organisme
interministériel qui est proche de du
mystère la défense et aussi de ministère
de l'intérieur avec une vision très
préfectoral très étatique avec une
obsession pour
menace terroriste et qui honnêtement hap
a mis un peu de côté la sécurité
sanitaire ce n'était pas une priorité
or derrière ces sigles et acronymes il
ya une réalité c'est que la gestion de
la politique de prêt de prévention ou de
précaution au choix sanitaire de la
france a été mise de côté alors que alla
jusqu alors l est et l est est impulsée
par le ministre de la santé lui même et
la cc passer sous les fourches caudines
des hauts fonctionnaires qui ont
considéré effectivement comme le disait
gérard que d'une part les masques
destinés aux professionnels bas c'était
aux professionnels de santé ne s'en
dépatouiller sauf qu'ils n'avaient pas
les moyens de faire donc ils n'ont pas
fait et que les masques chirurgicaux
ok l'état va l'équipe allait conserver
en fait on va les garder sous une autre
coupe mais sauf qu'on va même pas se
préoccuper de savoir si les stocks
continuent à augmenter ou à diminuer
parce que toute façon ça ne sert jamais
l'idée c'est que station ça sert à rien
ça ne sert à rien parce que les français
ne mettront pas et puis toute façon la
seule fois on est une épidémie un peu un
peu monstrueux c'est à dire h1n1 bon en
fait ça a fait pschitt et on nous à nous
alerter pour pas grand chose
donc ces différents phénomènes vont vont
contribuer à alimenter la j'allais dire
la déroute à venir je tombe cette
déroute à venir vous expliquer on
parlait de ce constat de masques très
important qu'est ce qui se passe avec
ses masques alors on s'est peut-être
pour expliquer c'est qu'un masque il ya
une durée de vie qui a acheté en 2000 ou
de quelques années il est peut-être
moins voilà alors des nuances à
expliquer ces actes eux mans donc même
si justement qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on
fait c'est masquer la forêt vue de
global alors c'est très important ce que
ce que ce que vous soulignez parce que
là dessus il ya eu il faut le dire est
une sorte d' intoxication politique qui
n'est pas neutre
c'est de partir du postulat qu'un masque
c'est comme un yaourt sasp et rim comme
un yaourt c'est à dire qu'il ya un
moment il ya une date on peut plus
manger si on va s'opposer il faut le
jeter
eh bien nous les spécialistes qu'on a
interrogés et je crois pas qu'on ait été
démentie sur ce point nous disent que
s'agissant par exemple des masques
chirurgicaux donc ce masque grand public
ce que que tout le monde essaie de
trouver désespérément et payent au prix
fort ce sont des masques qui au départ
n'avait pas de date de péremption
pourquoi parce que ce genre de masque
c'est exactement comme votre t-shirt
comme mon costume etc
et c'est encore mieux même parce que
votre t-shirt mon costume ils vont se
démoder le masque il ya pas de mode
heureusement mais par contre le masque
s'il est bien conservé c'est très
important s'il est très bien conservé il
peut durer très très longtemps des
décennies des décennies le seul petit
problème qui pourra y avoir
éventuellement celle élastique qui va se
détendre mais ce n'est pas dramatique on
peut en mettre un autre on peut
on peut faire un noeud etc dans tous les
cas le masque lui même au départ n'a pas
de date de péremption
ce n'est que très récemment il ya
quelques années des industriels du
masque ont décidé de mettre eux mêmes si
vous voulez 100 kg et de normes sans que
ce soit obligatoire de mettre des
masques
las pour le coup c'est les excès du
principe de précaution ils ont si jamais
un jour il ya un élastique qui casse il
ya quelqu'un qui nous fait un procès on
va quand même se couvrir on va mettre
une date de péremption
mais les spécialistes qu'on a vus nous
disent que ce n'est pas nécessaire la
preuve
la preuve vous avez aujourd'hui plein
d'élus locaux qui nous disent mais nous
j'ai plus pensé à françois rebsamen le
maire de dijon qui récemment a dit j'ai
retrouvé dans mes stocks des masques qui
ont plus de dix ou quinze ans qui était
officiellement à périmés mais qui était
très vieux et on les a ressorti pour les
donner à nos administrés
il ya plein de témoignages de gens qui
montrent que les masques peuvent durer
très longtemps donc l'histoire de la
péremption attention c'est un élément de
langage qui est qui est sorti
aujourd'hui notamment par olivier
ferrand pour dire qu'arras nous avons
jeté les masses parce qu'ils étaient
périmés non non on a brûlé des masques
et pas parce qu'ils étaient périmés mais
parce qu'ils étaient abîmées et pas
pourquoi ils ont été abîmés qu'ils
étaient mal conservée parce que c'est un
autre point essentiel qui a été
complètement laissés de côté c'est à
dire que les masques si vous les
entretenez pas dans des bonnes
conditions et ça coûte de l'argent c'est
vrai ils vont commencer à moisir et
c'est ce qui s'est passé au site pour
une partie des stocks de l'état
mais ça c'est pas c'est pas le fait du
hasard c'est parce qu'on les a pas
entretenues comme il fallait dire
quelque part donc ces stocks sont en
train clair ils sont mal entretenues
c'est ce qu'il fait qu' ils deviennent
inutilisables
exactement c'est ce qui explique en
grande partie que entre 2017 et 2020
dans appartiennent aux mots agnès buzyn
devient ministre de la santé puis
ensuite les libérant 600 millions de
masques vont disparaître et des stocks
de l'état 600 millions de masques
chirurgicaux vont disparaître ils vont
disparaître comment ils vont être
incinérés et vous les trois dernières
années oui sur le 10/07/2010 26 100
millions de bahts disparaissent et
marisol touraine forme alignement nous a
pas posé la question dans les colonnes
du monde en 10 ans mais que sont devenus
ces 600 millions de masques et
évidemment qu'elle pose cette question
avec une arrière-pensée très politique
bien sûr que c'est vrai quand elle est
partie de son mystère de la santé en
marisol touraine y avait 7 114 millions
de masques en stock chirurgicaux quand
et on s'est retrouvés trois ans plus
tard avec une 117 millions il a 600
millions près disparu
ceux ci sont mignons ils ont été
détruits parce que ils avaient été soit
20 entretenu pour une grande partie est
donc effectivement abîmée soit parce
qu'il y avait une date de péremption et
que l'administration dans sa grande
sagesse habituel a décidé qu'il fallait
les brûler parce que y avait une date de
péremption sans même vérifier qu'ils
étaient ou pas utilisable c'est ça le
scandale absolu
il ya beaucoup de scandales dans cette
histoire mais c'est aussi l'un des
scandales important c'est que il ya eu
600 millions de masse qui ont été brûlés
sans raison valable
je donne un exemple parmi les masses qui
donc que portait une date de péremption
mais qui était qui étaient les moins
nombreux les plus nombreux datait des
années 2005 2006 donc époque à laquelle
on décida au cours de laquelle ont
décidé de ne pas mettre de date de
péremption
mais même ceux qui sont qui ont été
acquis notamment dans les années 2014
2015 2016 donc sous marisol touraine
pour renouveler les stocks
cela avait en général une date de
péremption de 5 ans donc par exemple
ceux qui ont été acquis en 2014
en 2019 officiellement ils sont au bout
de la date de péremption
mais il était en état parfait évidemment
cinq ans alors qu'on voit qu'on en garde
qui ont 15 ans qui sont en très bonne
état
ceux de cinq ans était en bon état mais
sauf que pour l'administration a placé
les cinq en 2019 on commence à brûler et
donc on a brûlé ce qui était très vieux
qui était encore en bon état
ce qui est intéressant mais qui avait
une date officielle qui était qui était
dépassée alors qu'ils étaient encore en
meilleur état
et enfin on en a brûlé aussi qui était
objectivement en très mauvais état y
avait rien à en faire si ce n'est à les
brûler mais il aurait peut-être fallu
penser à les mieux conservées et surtout
à les renouveler
or on n'a fait ni l'un ni l'autre parce
que ce sont ces masses qui sont
conservés ou c'est un peu la question
qu'on se pose parce que on l'a vu durant
cette crise sanitaire
une fois des élus qui vont tomber par
hasard sur des des masques fait part
dans des greniers ou presse mais elle te
dire ah bah voilà moi je suis arrivé en
fonction si on parle d'un maire en 2014
ces masques étaient là avant et en
fouillant un peu partout on les trouve
une hausse à venir qui sont conservés
comment la plupart du temps dans les
mairies donc il ya des entrepôts ça se
passe comme il est avec la doctrine dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure
effectivement les employeurs comme les
différents établissements hospitaliers
ont eu comme mission d'acheter des mâts
certains l'ont fait d'autres noms au
monde par exemple on avait acheté des
masques et donc on a pu avoir des
masques au tout début
masques chirurgicaux
c'était valable dans plusieurs
entreprises dont plein d'entreprises
d'ailleurs et dans beaucoup de mairies
ou de régions mais simplement le
problème c'est que n'avait pas beaucoup
déjà parce que c'était pas calculé au
millimètre près et tout le monde en
avait pas et enfin ils n'étaient pas
forcément stockés dans des bonnes
conditions donc effectivement dans
certaines mairies et les mâts se sont
révélés totalement défectueux et le
problème de l'état c'est que l'état n'a
pas été capable dit justement de fournir
ces de renouveler les stocks
le problème de base c'est que ils ont
fait aussi une histoire d'argent il ya
toujours un moment donné où la question
budgétaire s'impose en france et là on a
eu des chiffres précis 1 100 millions de
masques commandés en période hors crise
ça coûte 3 2 millions d'euros
c'est pas monstrueux quand on veut juste
de ce que va coûter aujourd'hui la crise
sanitaire franchement et de ce que ça
sauve comme vie ben le simple fait de
dépenser trop bien d'imputer ligne
budgétaire au masque c'est est vécu
comme étant quelque chose de
problématique au sein du ministère de la
santé et donc ils n'ont ils ont pas
renouveler les stocks et ses stocks
étaient conservés effectivement dans un
entrepôt principal qui était du côté de
l'as dans la banlieue de la lointaine
banlieue parisienne sous administration
plus tôt militaire mais c'était moins
bien fait qu'à l'époque de l'eprus dont
je parlais tout à l'heure parce que les
plus a été dissous l'établissement qui
étaient chargés de gérer tous ces stocks
a été dissous et inséré dans un grand
ensemble qui s'appelle santé publique
france et la fatalement on perd en
compétences et en qualité
et par ailleurs il y avait des
entreprises aussi régionaux à
disposition de l'état qui était le aussi
disséminant le territoire pour donner
des masques dont les régions simplement
là aussi la conservation du masque un
point important la rigueur budgétaire ça
c'est quelque chose qui malheureusement
va j'allais dire va traverser les
différents gouvernements dont on a parlé
roselyne bachelot nous dit elle même
même si son bilan et de ce point de vue
là est bon il a été réhabilité la
lumière de la crise du coc vide mais
elle même dit que au cours des années
sarkozy avec la fameuse rgpp donc la
révision générale des politiques
publiques
en gros c'était quoi c'était les
restrictions budgétaires il faut faire
il faut faire des coupes un peu partout
et le ministère de la santé a été
impacté par sa sous marisol touraine
on en a eu la confirmation notamment par
la personne qui est à l'époque était le
directeur général de la santé donc
l'homme clé de tout ce dispositif
il nous dit en gros on récupère le
ministère de la santé donc
2012 avec dans les stocks d'état à peu
près 700 millions de masques l'objectif
c'est d'arriver donc au fameux milliards
la doctrine du milliard pour être à peu
près tranquille il en faut un milliard
il dit au début on a essayé de tenir cet
objectif en se disant c'est simple on va
abonder notre réserve de 100 millions de
masques
chaque année voilà si on en fait 100
millions sur cinq ans pas besoin d'avoir
été fait d'avoir fait de grandes études
pour comprendre qu'on sera au-dessus du
milliard et pourtant c'est pas ce qui va
se passer puisque marisol touraine le
reconnaît elle même quand elle est
partie elle a rendu le stock à peu près
au niveau avec 750 millions de masques
ont peu à peu près en stock ce qui n'est
pas honteux mais ce qui est quand même
pas suffisant par rapport à l'objectif
affiché est pourquoi le directeur
général de la santé nous dit très très
très sincèrement il nous dit il ya eu
des problèmes budgétaires des
restrictions budgétaires il a fallu
faire des choix en plus malheureusement
c'est une période il ya eu d'autres
événements les attentats avec des
besoins pour les hôpitaux de fourniture
de masques évidemment l'épidémie ebola
et d'autres phénomènes ponctuels qui ont
vidé les stocks de l'état
donc on a quand même un peu remplacés
pour garder le stock à peu près comme on
l'avait trouvé
nous on a pas pour n'a pas trouvé les
financements pour faire c'est finalement
300 400 millions de plus de masse qui
aurait dû être qu'ils auraient dû être
produit et est entreposé or quand on
pense aux chiffres qui évoquait gérard
qui a environ 3 millions d'euros pour
100 millions de masques
il en manquait je veux dire c'est ça
veut dire que il y avait besoin de
quelques même pas une dizaine de
millions d'euros pour qu'on soit au
niveau et malgré tout on n'a pas fait
cet effort là et tout ça ça traduit
quelque chose ça traduit que ça n'a
jamais était depuis 2010 n'a plus jamais
été une priorité
ces histoires de pandémie un peu vous
savez c'est quand on fait peur à
quelqu'un en lui on lui on lui faisant
croire qu'il va se passer quelque chose
et que ça n'arrive jamais on fait
l'allusion au désert des tartares c'est
exactement ça eh bien au bout d'un
moment
à force vous faire peur pour rien vous
n'avez plus jamais peur eh bien c'est ce
qui s'est passé et c'est pour ça qu'on
sait désormais elles sont clairement
quand on brûle ses masques on les
remplace pas il n'y a pas une idée de se
dire bon ma le stock diminue parce que
justement où les détruit il n'y a aucune
commande kir précédera c'est la
destruction pure et simple écrit
l'auteur je crois me souvenir qu'il ya
une commande qui a été faite de 60
millions d'euros de dessous 5 millions
de masques en 2019 c'est ça je crois
voilà mais ça s'arrête là ils n'ont pas
non pas se voulait le chiffre de base
c'est un milliard d'euros il faut un
milliard de masques en france pour faire
face à une pandémie c'est à survient à
tout moment et bien là ils ont commandé
au maximum 60
durant de 60 millions de masques durant
les trois dernières années donc c'est
vraiment très peu si l'on se tourné
quand même masque au final au total au
moment où la l'épidémie en france
à en croire le gouvernement lui-même et
nous ont dit qu'ils restaient 117
millions en stock
en réalité ils se sont trompés et
puisque après si on observe les
déclarations qu'ils ont faites après que
la polémique a été déclenchée notamment
par les révélations de la presse et
celle du monde il ya ce coup ils ont dit
non en fait il aurait 160 millions parce
qu'on en a retrouvé et c'est parce que
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'au
moment où ils les articles de presse
commencent à apparaître
ils sont 10 mai où là il ya dû avoir un
bug ils ont récupéré en catastrophe des
masques qui était prévu qu'ils étaient
eux-mêmes en train c'est ce qu'on a
révélé dans nos pratiques qui étaient en
train d'être détruit mais dans tous les
cas même qu'ils en récupèrent quelques
dizaines de millions au mieux il en
restait 150 millions qui n'avait pas été
détruit mais c'est une minuscule par
rapport au stock dont on aurait dû
disposer il ya deuxième problème qui se
pose est gentil si peut-être votre
question mais le problème qui se pose
c'est non seulement il ya plus de
masquer une en plus pendant très
longtemps ils ont prétendu que le masque
ne servait à rien il faut se souvenir
des expressions employées par edouard
philippe le 13 mars
quand il dit le mas ne sert pas à
grand-chose en substance cib et n'diaye
va relayer sa en tant que porte parole
du gouvernement de manière très très
zélés comme d'habitude et en se
réfugiant derrière l' oms l'om est dit
que bon le ms c'est très bien mais il
aurait été encore tellement plus simple
en fait de compulser de regarder les
quelques rapports dont celui qui était
sorti en juin 2019
disons concrètement fait par le haut
comité oui le haut-conseil la santé
publique hcsp encore un acronyme qui
disait concrètement que les masques il
en faut un milliard et c'est
indispensable en cas de pandémie il n'y
a pas besoin d'aller consulter le msc
d'attendre ce qui le ms 10 et
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
il suffisait d'écouter ce que disait
l'expérience des experts en france les
masques sont juste indispensable et on
se rend compte maintenant tellement
aujourd'hui indispensable pour faire
face à une pandémie est évité des
milliers de morts donc ils ont non
seulement pas gérer les stocks
ils les ont pas renouveler ils les ont
détruit qu'on ne fallait pas les
détruire mais en plus derrière il faut
bien l'avouer ils ont habillé leur leur
espèce de
d'incurie qu'ils ont habillé savais
qu'avec un langage de communicants qui
va leur revenir tel un boomerang ou la
l'heure des comptes
je pense que ça le savent allait plomber
où les pénaliser durablement l'exécutif
le mystère la santé enfin tous ceux qui
ont qui ont qui ont plaidé de manière
c'est à dire assez absurde contre le
masque parce que ils se heurtent je
pense au bon sens de l'opinion publique
et pour le coup c'est pas du poujadisme
c'est juste une évidence les gens se
disent mais quand même ça paraît logique
qu'avec un masque on soit plus protégé
que sans et puis une petite question
subsidiaire au fait si les masses ça
sert à rien c'est bizarre qu'on en
produisant fait pourquoi les chirurgiens
dentistes pourquoi pourquoi les les gens
qui sont des propos dans des professions
va dire un peu exposé traditionnellement
hors pandémie pourquoi ils mettent des
masques même des masques chirurgicaux je
parle même pas de ffp2 mais parce que ça
protège et par ailleurs on parlait tout
à l'heure des différences entre ffp2
donc qui sont les masques effectivement
au bec de canard qui sont plus
perfectionné un peu plus pénible
apporter aussi qu'ils sont réservés aux
professionnels c'est vrai qu'ils ont un
taux de filtration comme on dit proche
de 100% 90 94 % savent bien qu'on est
très protégée et qu'on protège les
autres dans les deux sens
les masques chirurgicaux c'est vrai
qu'on va surtout protéger les autres
mais en terme de pouvoir de filtration
c'est au minimum 40 % certaines études
dix 60% donc ça veut dire que c'est pas
neutre on peut pas dire je mets un
masque mais en fait non façon ça sert à
rien c'est juste pour rigoler c'est pour
faire joli si tenté que ça fasse de
livres mais en tous les cas non les
masses ça sert vraiment et je pense que
là il ya une erreur même de
communication en dehors du scandale
sanitaire et une erreur de communication
de dire aux gens non mais les masques on
vous en a parlé mais je croyais et
croyez nous ça sert strictement rien les
gens c'est absurde et j'en veux pour
preuve un
il ya eu une publicité qui était
retrouvé par un de nos lecteurs et qui
nous a gentiment redresser sa en top
santé le magazine top santé magazine qui
est passé en printemps 2010 9 en 2019 il
ya un an
ces publicités c'est sur une pleine page
c'est une personne avec un masque ses
publicités elle a été payée par là j'en
serai jamais la santé et par santé
publique france ile de france qui dit
concrètement avec l'arrivée de la grippe
mettez des masques c'est la seule
manière de se protéger 2019
et on ne parle pas les craintes d'une
pandémie mondiale de la grippe
saisonnière il ya un an plus tard c'est
cette même administration la santé va
dire ça sert à rien non à un moment
donné on peut pas prendre les gens pour
des imbéciles
trop longtemps quoi alors on sait
justement au niveau des masques ils ont
été réquisitionnés très rapidement c'est
à dire retirer de la vente au grand
public pour les réserver justement aux
professionnels de santé et avec ses
discours juste que vous évoquez de dire
ah bah c'est maïs finalement ça sert pas
à grand chose c'est pas forcément utile
sauf si vous êtes malade et serait ce
que par rapport à l' enquête que vous
avez pu faire ça révélerait quelque part
que ce discours politique était un
moment donné pour cacher cette pénurie
pour dire on m'a finalement on regarde
ces masques pour les professions de
santé
vous en avez pas besoin donc voilà c'est
c'est je dirais que c'est la déduction
de bon sens qu'on peut faire parce que
sinon pourquoi avoir pourquoi avoir dit
ce qui allait en dépit de l'évidence et
en dépit des propres rapports que que le
gouvernement avait et en dépit comme
disait gérard des campagnes de
communication que monet ce même
gouvernement qui tout tout ce que je
viens de dire la allé dans le même sens
les masses ça sert à quelque chose il
faut en avoir y compris pour le citoyen
moyen
la seule la seule explication
rationnelle du fait qu'à un moment on
nous a dit non non en fait les masses ça
ne sert à rien c'est même presque
dangereux c'est parce que il savait
qu'il y en avait plus dans les caisses
il y avait plus rien et il avait du mal
à assumer cette pénurie alors qu'il a
mon avis tu aurais dû faire preuve de
sincérité de transparence en disant
voilà les stocks sont vides on a tous
fauté quelque part mais on va se
rattraper
ils s'étaient ils ont estimé que
politiquement ce n'était pas tenable
donc ils ont plutôt dit plutôt que de
dire il ya plus de mal dans les caisses
qu'on apprendra de vie effectivement
mais massa sert à rien mais sauf ça leur
revient dans la figure jusqu'à
maintenant ils sont perdants sur les
souliers sur les deux points sur les
deux plans parce que ce que vous évoquez
dans votre enquête dans la chronologie
et aussi des faits de ce qui se passe
sur territoire pendant ce temps là et
vous évoquez notamment la fermeture de
la dernière usine française de
production de masques basée à plaintel
dans les côtes d'armor qui a fermé ses
portes donc il ya 2
et c'était une catastrophe d'un point de
vue local mais aussi ça veut dire que il
ya une dépendance d'autres pays
notamment vis-à-vis de l'asie pour la
production des masses c'est à dire qu'on
perd entre guillemets une souveraineté
nationale pour produire les masques sur
notre propre sol
mais on parle des basses mais c'est
valable aussi évidemment pour tous qui
est médicaments on est tout à fait
dépendant de ce qui se passe en asie et
en chine aux particuliers mais pour les
masquer oui c'est d'autant plus rageant
qu'en fait il y a quelques années sous
l'impulsion il faut bien le dire de
dominique de villepin de jacques chirac
et in fine et de xavier bertrand
on avait mis en place une filière
industrielle il y avait au moins quatre
entreprises en france qui produisait des
dizaines de millions de masques
chirurgicaux et ffp2 de très bonne
qualité qui venait gonfler les stocks de
l'état
il y avait des commandes d'état
estampillées qui durait cinq ans qui
devait être ensuite avec des clauses qui
permettait de renouveler les stocks une
fois que les masques et venait
éventuellement à péremption mais lorsque
expliqué fabrice y avait pas forcément
de péremption
mais il n'empêche j'avais une clause qui
a été prévu donc tout était prévu et
parmi ces entreprises il ya
effectivement l'entreprise bacou dalloz
qui ce kit installé à plaintel et on a
interrogé longuement son ancien
président qui nous expliquait que tout
était car équipe où il avait mis en
perce d'aider des chaînes industrielles
il avait commandé les nouvelles machines
ça fonctionnelle du feu de dieu et que
peu à peu un peu c'est pas parce qu'à 5
ou peu les commandes ont décru peu à peu
quelqu un je ne sais pas qui parce que
le propre du jour 10 qui ne sait pas
c'est de dire il ne sais pas moi je
pense qu'il faut le suivre il lui non
plus ne sais pas qui a dit stop
mais la machine à commandes s'est tari
voilà et donc du coup cette entreprise
est morte de sa belle mort en 2018 le
problème à mon avis c'est quand gérard
dit qu'on ne sait pas qui a donné cet
ordre ni le nil entrepreneurs ni nous
journalistes
le problème c'est que je ne sais pas si
quelqu'un en france le seul y compris au
sommet du gouvernement et ça fait partie
des questions que soulève à mon avis l
enquête qu on a mené c'est à dire que à
un moment c'est d'ailleurs là sans faire
de sport digne mais là chut l'un de nos
articles
xavier bertrand qu'il dit mais au fait
qui décide et c'est un homme politique
qui vous dit ça et il a raison parce que
nous même on se pose la question
et quand on oppose à marisol touraine
donc été émise de la santé de 2012 à
2017 donc il ya qui connaît quand même
son sujet et qui a plutôt aller c'est un
nain prévenu bonne impression dans ce
cas la fin elle a pas été spécialement
attaquer
même si sur les masques encore une fois
on l'a dit pour des raisons budgétaires
il y avait mieux à faire
mais même marisol touraine a maintenant
quand on lui dit mais notamment ce
changement de doctrine le fait que
l'état arrête de s'occuper des masques
ffp2 fasse confiance aux entrepreneurs
aux employeurs et que l'état n'avait pas
vérifié si les stocks sont toujours en
état etc
vous avez fait ce qu'a dit votre
administration et là elle dit avec une
candeur assez désarmante et 10 mai enfin
moi je fais appel à des experts des gens
qui sont assermentés des gens qui sont
expérimentés des gens qui sont des
spécialistes
et ces gens me rendent leurs conclusions
est ce que vous voyez que moi ministre
j'aille leur dire non vous avez tort je
sais mieux que ses experts donc c'est
intéressant parce qu'on est dans une
matière effectivement qui réclame une
expertise mais il ya un moment
est-ce qu'on n'est pas passé dans ce
qu'on appelle parfois la république des
scientifiques ou plutôt à mon avis des
experts et des technocrates qui fait que
des décisions sont prises et que les
politiques ne sont pas ceux qui décident
mais ce qui avalise qui valide ce que la
raf faire monter l'administration alors
il ya énormément de rapports différents
c'est ce que vous évoquez tout en
l'ouvrant quête à partir de 2005 c'est
des rapports parfois plus ou moins
alarmant c'est ce qu'on a évoqué aussi
dans les dé dire baba la séance et
masques etc
ça a été évoqué plusieurs fois il faut
tel nombre de masse pour faire face à
une épidémie 1 milliard mais dans tous
ces rapports et notamment aussi jérôme
salomon qui est maintenant le directeur
général de la santé qui était auparavant
conseillé je crois que marisol touraine
c'est ça et qui donc à ce moment là
donnent une note alarmiste sur ce sujet
là et va refaire de même durant la
campagne présidentielle où il se
rapproche des mâles mâcon qui à l'époque
est candidat c'est ça c'est ça sur mme
salomon c'est un incontesté spécialistes
de tout ce qui est pandémie épidémie
à tel point qu'il avait dans son bureau
quand il était conseiller de mme buzyn
une affiche où il a marqué nous allons
tous mourir en anglais gouillart taille
et c'est un vrai spécialiste et il a il
a eu de cesse d'alerter madame touraine
et
et c'est différent supérieur sur les
dangers d'une épidémie s'il venait à
survenir et c'est ce qui veut dire qu
ensuite quand il est passé comme
beaucoup d'autres avec armes et bagages
et connaissances scientifiques dans le
combat kron aparté de l'automne 2016 il
a donc conduit une note qu'il a été
révélé ensuite dans les maquereaux l'x
vous savez c'est fluide quand de
documents qui ont été publiés on sait
pas pas trop au parquet mais qui sont
sortis pour le camp présidentiel
il y avait cette note de jérôme salomon
qui disait attention en cas de gros coup
de grisou que ce soit ya un attentat ou
autres choses la france n'est pas équipé
en termes de sécurité sanitaire on n'est
pas équipé il vraiment c'est un vrai
coup de gueule et et derrière ensuite
quelques mois plus tard il est nommé
directeur général de la santé comme quoi
ça marche comme de passer avec armes et
bagages dans le camp ennemi est en fait
la vraie question qui se pose et c'est
pas nous qui la posons c'est manuel
valls à 1 l'ancien premier ministre
socialiste est en séminaire intérieur
qui dit mais attention moi je sais bien
jérôme simplement je sais très bien
qu'il était au cabinet de madame
touraine maintenant qu'il y ait des gs
on peut poser la question qu'est ce
qu'il a fait de 2018 2020 pour réarmer
la france d'un préfet sanitaire alors
que c'était le mieux placé le plus grand
connaisseur soi-disant et et l'homme qui
poussaient des cris des larmes
que s'est il passé entre 2018 et 2020 et
c'est une question qu'on aurait aimé
vraiment posées à jérôme salomon et on a
essayé alors justement c'est peut-être
intéressant parce que il ya ces enquêtes
alors bah ouais on vous l'évoquez dans
le temps il joue un steak est aussi
l'idée d'aller poser des questions aux
principaux concernés j'imagine que vous
avez vu vous rapprocher de lille vers
ans jérôme salomon d'autres personnes
que vous évoquez l'un des contextes et
marisol touraine roselyne bachelot mais
ceux qui sont en charge de la
responsabilité maintenant d'un point de
vue gouvernemental ou d'un point de vue
de la santé on parle de jérôme salomon
est-ce que vous avez des retours des
réponses à vos questionnements alors
c'est assez troublant parce
qu'effectivement pour faire cette
enquête qui était ambitieuse puisque on
prenait quasiment 20 ans d'histoire
sanitaire de la france donc c'était ça
faisait du bon boulot et beaucoup de
gens à contacter et nous non dans ce cas
là on contacte un peu tout le monde
assez normal et surtout les personnes
qui sont en position de répondre parce
qu'elles ont la compétence et
éventuellement qui peuvent être mises en
cause par le par les informations qu'on
recueille et bien toulouse a répondu
sauf toute l'équipe qui est en place
depuis 2017 ou 2018 donc c'est quand
même assez troublant si vous voulez donc
on a eu tous les anciens ministres de la
santé tous les anciens directeur général
de la santé
tout tout tout les ai tous les hauts
fonctionnaires qui étaient en poste
auparavant l'aïe a pas de problème et là
bizarrement jérôme c'est le monde n'a
jamais retourné nos appels
olive et veyran pas plus agnès buzyn pas
de réponse la direction générale de la
santé en tant que tel pas de réponse
nissarda sentais pas de réponse en tant
que telle la seule qu'on a réussi à
faire parler un petit peu et la patronne
de santé publique france et je peux vous
dire que c'est des places du harcèlement
journalistique pour obtenir une réponse
mais alors quelle réponse était voilà ce
qu'on appelle de la langue de bois après
elle a le droit bien entendu cette femme
jeune vieille chaîne mais pour vous dire
moi c'est la première fois que ça
m'arrive dans une interview par
téléphone puisqu'on est évidemment via
skype avec gérard on a interrogé cette
personne est qu après qu'on ait posé nos
questions on entendait un grand silence
un grand blanc comme en fait elle nous
mettait en attente
c'était qu'un vent de répondre à nos
questions elle consultait ses
conseillers donc c'était une façon on va
dire pas idéal de communiquer mais au
moins on peut on peut il faut donner le
crédit d'avoir répondu à quelques unes
de nos questions
elle a pas répondu grand chose elle a
dit qu'elle venait à peine d'arriver
qu'elle avait pas grand chose à dire
mais nous avions la fédé important c'est
qu'elle nous a dit effectivement nous
avons détruit des stocks elle a au moins
confirmé sa ce qui était pas rien donc
là on évoquer la situation du rhône
simplement les notes qu'ils sont
émise au moment où il est conseiller
marisol touraine l'on appelle qui ont
ces ministres de la santé durant le
quinquennat de françois hollande
ensuite on l'évoqué aussi et mâcon se
présente à la présidence de la
république avant d'être élu bat jérôme
salle on se rapproche de lui et et mais
également des notes également sur ces
sujets là donc quelque part il ya une
expertise qui comprend cette situation
qui explique les choses est plutôt bien
a priori mais il n'y a pas de pratique
derrière c'est ça il se passe rien
exactement c'est assez troublant il faut
bien le dire parce qu'il se passe
effectivement pas grand chose derrière
agnès buzyn est nommé ministre de la
santé alors c'est une hyper spécialistes
de la santé ça personne ne peut le
contester de la sécurité sanitaire c'est
autre chose c'est un autre domaine et
c'est un domaine à temps complet et avec
une il faut avoir des connaissances très
précises et qui l'a t-elle nommer à son
cabinet dès qu'elle est installée avenue
de ségur avait nommé un médecin
généraliste qui sera chargé de faire la
sécurité sanitaire de la france il sera
conseiller technique chargé de la
sécurité sanitaire
il se trouve que ce monsieur on a essayé
de contacter il a refusé de nous
répondre aussi en dix ans dix ans je
préfère répondre à la future commission
denquête cet homme là était médecin
généraliste il y reste 18 mois et les
médecins généralistes dans l'est de la
france et il n'y connaissait évidemment
absolument rien à la sécurité sanitaire
de la france et donc c'est une des
raisons pour laquelle il n'a pas voulu
répondre je pense sans vouloir lui faire
de procès d'intention et donc ça montre
bien que ce n'était pas une priorité de
ce ministère la de la santé c'est certes
ils avaient et ils ont le droit d'avoir
des prix d'autres priorités à marisol
touraine par exemple c'était de le
budget de la sécu agnès buzyn c'était
autre chose
s'occuper des hôpitaux et si j'en crois
les hôpitaux a priori ce n'était pas
très content quand même
mais en tout cas la sécurité sanitaire
de la france n'était pas la priorité de
manuel macro quand il est arrivé au
pouvoir c'est une certitude
alors dans les colonnes du mondial dit
cette ancienne interview justement avec
agnès buzyn l'enjeu pensez vous que
l'avenant chemin ariane chemin donc est
aussi journaliste au monde qui va avoir
une interview avec agnès buzyn et qui
quelque part affirme que dès janvier
2001 elle voyait ce tsunami épidémique à
venir serre que quelque part dès janvier
alors qu'il y avait des discours de dire
l'importation du virus est quasi faible
le fait que ça se répand dans la
population également
et finalement en parallèle elle aurait
alerté l'exécutif de dire attention la
situation qui va arriver dans les
prochaines semaines dans les prochains
mois va être graves
finalement ma ce qu'on est en train de
vivre en ce moment c'est ça c'est pour
ça qu'on a aussi essayé de joindre agnès
buzyn parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
questions à lui poser sur la on dire la
politique sanitaire mais aussi il y
aurait besoin qu'elles éclaircissent ces
propos là parce que ces propos ont fait
scandale et je pense que c'est normal
qu'ils aient fait scandale parce qu'ils
sont choquants parce que souvenez de
deux choses l'une soit ce que dit agnès
buzyn exactement ce qui s'est passé
c'est à dire qu'elle a alerté l'exécutif
en amont en disant il va se passer des
choses dramatiques et l'exécutif macron
comme philippe non non pas du tout tenu
compte et dans ce cas là oui c'est
gravissime
soit elle est juste amer d'avoir daouda
vous d'avoir été humilié mais battu au
premier tour delà de la candidate de sa
candidature à la mairie de paris et elle
refait un peu l'histoire mais c'est
totalement irresponsable ou dans les
deux cas il ya c'est sûr qu'il ya un
problème busan ya un problème buzyn et
ce qui est gênant c'est que c'est quand
même une responsable politique elle n'a
pas une grande carrière de femme
politique mais elle a accepté des
responsabilités ministre de la santé
candidat du parti majoritaire à la
mairie de paris il faut avoir ce qu'on
appelle le sens des responsabilités donc
là c'est vrai que par rapport au citoyen
lambda qui ont entendu ses déclarations
honnêtement c'est préoccupant inquiétant
et cette demande des explications mais
ça revient à ce qu'on disait
précédemment
il y a deux ans dans toute la crise de
la part du pouvoir macro nice il ya eu
une volonté de communication on peut pas
leur reprocher il faut les français
voulaient entendre des réponses mais le
problème c'est que c'était la
communication j'ai à dire à sens unique
il n'y a pas on ne répond pas aux
questions il ya des questions sur agnès
buzyn celle que vous soulevez à travers
ses propos tonitruants au monde
il ya les questions par rapport à la
police sanitaire l'attitude jérôme
seulement pourquoi n'at-il rien fait il
ya propos par rapport au stock pourquoi
les at-on pas entretenues pourquoi
n'at-on pas renouvelé etc etc et sur
toutes ces questions on n'a aucune
réponse aucune réponse
et ça c'est certain c'est un souci je
vais toutes les personnes qui nous
regardent actuellement on va encore est
ensemble quelques minutes pour aborder
quelques questions qui éventuellement
dans les commentaires n'hésitez pas à
réagir à poser vos questions si vous
avez balades et des précisions que vous
souhaitez demander
n'hésitez pas cela il y aussi ce fait
pour ça pour puissiez réagir poser des
questions dans les commentaires
donc n'hésitez pas à réagir à partager
ce direct a commenté on est là avec vous
encore pendant quelques minutes
et puis à savoir pour tous ceux qui
viennent d'arriver en cours de l'ail que
l'ensemble ne facebook like sont
toujours disponibles en intégralité
henry pech juste après vous arriver
juste juste maintenant vous avez loupé
je pense une bonne partie de ce direct
on a évoqué pas mal de choses et bien
juste après en replay vous pourrez le
voir ou de revoir en intégralité
il ya ces questions justement on évoquer
le les non-réponses may à l'assemblée
nationale quelque part oliveira a réagi
dit voilà on a détruit des masques moisi
inutilisable que vous ne donnerait même
pas à votre lapin à quelque part c'est
fair action indirecte à vos révélations
parce qu'il avait été interpellé à
l'assemblée nationale au sujet des
articles vous avez publié à ce moment-là
vous suscite quoi comme réaction quand
vous entendez ça que le bon mot
sur les lapins nains et amusant et la
plus simple et assez peu sympathique
pour les lapins nains et encore plus
désagréable je pense pour les français
qui cherchait des masques un peu partout
par ailleurs c'était une façon habile de
cacher la vérité c'est à dire que
concrètement oui et c'est vrai il ya des
masques hors d'usagé qui ont été
d'esprit et c'est normal et c'est
logique
la vraie question c'est pas celle là la
vraie question c'est pourquoi était-il
hors d'usagé parce qu'ils étaient mal
stockés et bien entretenus l'autre
question c'est est ce que il y en a pas
qui était encore en plein usage qui ont
été les esprits si c'est le cas il y en
a qui était utile indispensable et en
plein usage et qui ont été détruits par
les services de ce ver ans et enfin
pourquoi ne pas en avoir commandé de
nouveaux avant même que l'épidémie
viennent frapper la france
donc ces trois aspects là évidemment ils
les cachent derrière cette phrase là
mais il faut pas il faut pas prendre les
gens pour des imbéciles à un moment
donné la vérité apparaît exactement moi
je pense que c'est une c'est une réponse
très politique voire politicienne assez
habile parce que sa marque l'opinion il
a peint un oui c'est vrai il ya des
masses qui sont pourris donc évidemment
c'est normal de les détruire c'est du
bon sens ça mais sur le long terme ça va
lui revenir comme un boomerang
parce qu'il y aura des commission
denquête des enquêtes judiciaires après
les enquêtes journée ici qui vont
confirmer ce qu'on a écrit et qui vont
faire qu'on va se rendre compte que la
silhouette de la réponse d'olivier
ferrand en fait est totalement
surréaliste
imaginez que vous vous rendiez à
l'hôpital pour voir votre un de vos
proches qui serait très très mal qui
devrait subir une opération très
importante sa survie serait en jeu et
que et que vous disiez mais pourquoi on
le perd pas la sepur gens etc et que le
responsable de l'établissement viennent
nous voir en disant tu es monsieur suis
désolé en fait tous des produits pour
anesthésistes ont tous péri mais on
verra les bancs d'école c'est ou périmés
donc on va pas pouvoir l'opéra il va
mourir mais c'est pas possible
vous oublierez pendriez mais attendez
vous êtes le directeur de l'hôpital et
vous êtes en train de me dire que vos
produits sont périmés et c'est vous le
responsable donc quand il répond
naïvement faussement naïf mais enfin non
vous ne seriez pas donner à voir n'a pas
tellement ils sont pourris les masques
mais oui mais c'est juste à vous les
gardez de les garder en bon état sans
parler je ne parle même pas du fait
qu'il aurait dû en acheter plus en
commander etc
mais même le fait que les stocks soient
détruits on a l'impression que c'est une
fatalité qu il tombe sur le sur lucio
sur le sucre sur le dos en 2020 alors
qu'on parle d'un pouvoir qui est en
place depuis trois ans donc je pense que
ce cd genre de propos qui ce sont des
tripes des propos de tribunes comme on
dit qui peuvent qui peuvent nourrir deux
minutes au 20 heures mais quand il y
aura les enquêtes sérieuses ça sera une
autre paire de manche à mon avis dans la
proportion justement des masques on
évoquait justement les conditions de
conservation comme vous et justement la
destruction de certains mais il y en a
certains qui étaient encore tout à fait
fonctionnel oui et au dernier moment
matignon est intervenue et on s'est fait
confirmer cette information là est
intervenu pour stopper la destruction de
masques qui était encore tout à fait en
plein usage qui était tout à fait
indispensables à la protection des
populations
donc il ya vraiment eu cette cette
information lors de la sortie elle a été
vérifiée ensuite est confirmée par bfm
bresse avant d'ailleurs et on était sûr
de nous de toute façon bien sûr il ya eu
des millions de masques qui ont été
sauvés in extremis du bûcher après la
question qui nous est posée de savoir
combien il y en avait précisément
et bien cette question devant la pause
et des milliers de fois que ce soit à la
rs que ce soit la dgs que ce soit santé
publique france où hélas on n'a jamais
eu de réponse
donc notre je trouve que notre droit
notre devoir à nous journalistes d'
enquête c'est que quand on sait pas on
ne dit pas donc on ne sait pas combien
exactement il y en a mais il n'y a pas
la quantité à la lors de la phase 5
l'aimé et je pense qu'on le saura
on saura rapidement qu'avec des pouvoirs
d'enquêté qu'ils seront importants et
intéressants que ce que la justice ou
les enquêtes parlementaires et on saura
il ya quelque chose que je veux dire
qu'ils étaient très importants je trouve
moi qui est très qui très révélateur en
fait du système mac rogne aoun acronis
je ne sais pas comment on parle dit les
choses c'est que ce gouvernement là
aimerait on leur donne un satisfecit sur
la façon dont ils ont géré la crise et
de façon ils sont se sont démenés c'est
une vérité ils se sont démenés à partir
de quand la crise est arrivée pour
trouver des masques en catastrophe
trouver des tests catastrophe trouvé il
fallait tout trouvé en catastrophe
puisqu'on avait rien à partir de quand
c'est ça la question
souvent il ya beaucoup qui rage et ce
qu'ils disent bah oui aujourd'hui ça
bouge beaucoup mais est ce que je la
page et romain serman qu'il faut pas
leur faire de mauvais procès je pense
que quand la pandémie est arrivé ils ont
plein face ils se sont dit il faut qu'on
goûte se démène et je crois qu'ils sont
très nombreux à ne pas avoir dormi
pendant de longues nuits pour essayer
trouver des masques etc ça il faut pas
leur faire ce procès là je le pense
sincèrement
il suffit de lire les enquêtes les
reportages de 2 voilà je crois que c'est
vrai mais le le le problème et le
travail des journalistes d' enquêtes et
des journalistes et c'est ça que je
pense le gouvernement macro n'ya ne
comprends pas c'est de ne pas éclairer
nous travaillons c'est d'éclairer la
face sombre de montrer ce qui n'allait
pas pourquoi on en arriver là c'est pas
tellement de raconter les hauts faits
d'armes d'un fonctionnaire qui va se
battre face à aux américains pour
obtenir des basques savent bien sûr
qu'ils le font c'est leur blues
minimum qu'il doit faire mais
l'important c'était quand même avant que
je pense pas que tu me contredira
c'était de faire le boulot avant aussi
mais tout à fait et pour compléter ce
qu'on disait à l'instant même sur
l'évaluation des stocks qui était en
état ou pas il ya quand même une
personne qui au moins nous a répondu et
son témoignage est à lire dans la quête
du monde c'est benoît valley qui était
directeur général de la santé donc de
2013 à 2018 ses prédécesseurs de jérôme
salle au vent et qui lui a connu ces
femmes notamment ces fameux 600 millions
de masques qui datait des années 2005
2006 et qui vont pour l'essentiel ont
été brûlés lui dit puisqu'il est connaît
ses stocks lui dit que bonne partie de
ses stocks étaient utilisables
voilà et c'est lui qui l'affirment c'est
pas le sais pas comment dire hey c'est
un interlocuteur hyper crédible son
sérieux n'a jamais été mis en cause
la preuve il a même été appelés dans la
coordination pour le pour la gestion du
confinement
donc ça fait partie des témoins à mon
avis qui seront les témoins clés pour
les futures enquêtes qui auront lieu et
qui risque de devenir un des leaders un
témoin à charge comme il y en aura
beaucoup et surtout beaucoup de faits à
charge contre les équipes l'exécutif
actuel mais peut-être aussi
éventuellement les prédécesseurs qui
encore une fois ont mal géré ou pas du
tout géré d'ailleurs à mon avis ces
stocks de masques qui pourtant aurait
tellement été utile parce que justement
ces masses qui sont détruits jusqu'à
quand exactement
même pendant la pandémie ah oui oui
jusqu'au genou d'après nos informations
jusqu'à la dernière semaine du mois de
mars donc on en plein confinement et on
cherche des avantages du peu du pic
épidémique est à ce moment là donc nous
voilà donc jusqu'à fin mars
et ça s'arrête à ce moment là l'exécutif
semble reprendre les choses en main
c'est matignon se rend compte qui s'est
passé les jeux d'ailleurs ils ont
demandé une enquête interne au sein de
l'organisation de la santé 1 que soit dg
swire il ya eu des enquêtes qui ont été
menées interne pour comprendre ce qui
avait pu se passer et en attendant ils
ont dû gérer la pénurie parce qu'ils
sont rendu compte qu'on veut lui des
masques qui qui qui était encore tout à
fait de bon usage
donc c'est il était très furieux nous at
on dit à matignon exactement et ce qui
signifie qu'en mai mais là encore on en
revient à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
sur le fait que le pouvoir politique
s'est désintéressé de ses questions ou
en tout cas laisser l'administration
toute puissante
ce qui signifie qu alors qu'on est en
pleine pandémie que toute la france
cherche des masques et y compris le
gouvernement sa propre direction de la
santé et son propre organisme santé
publique france
détruire des masques sans faire remonter
si ça se trouve même le directeur
général de la santé n'a même pas été
informés parce que ça s'est passé à la
base savès et administratif au ces
masques il faut il faut les brûler tous
les tous les tous les cinq ans allait au
point on est pas si on les passe au
pilon et ça dénote aussi un j'allais
dire un ce dessaisissement traduit une
déconnexion entre le j'allais dire ce
que ce qu'on attend du pouvoir politique
et ce qui est ce qui fait réellement
il n'est pas normal que le pouvoir
politique ne soit pas au courant de ce
que fait son administration
quand on est sur des affaires aussi
importante évidemment je parle pas de
commander 10 boulons dans un coin là on
parle en fait de cesser d arbres en fait
c'est des armes de protection pour les
citoyens qui étaient purement et
simplement détruites alors que le
gouvernement de son côté on cherchait
c'est presque surréaliste
est-ce qu'on a un ordre de comparaison
par rapport à l'étranger on sait que ces
questions de pénurie de masques
notamment elles se sont posées aussi
dans d'autres pays
est ce que la france est plus touché
d'autres où finalement c'est un problème
mondial
moi de ce que je leur on n'a pas fait
une enquête internationale ça viendra
peut-être mais c'est nous prendre encore
plus de temps mais pourquoi pas non mais
dans ce que de ce qu'on a vu de ce qu'on
peut savoir ça a été un problème général
donc on pourrait dire oui mais la france
et c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit un peu le
pouvoir ont fait pas pire que les autres
et c'est d'abord ça reste à prouver mais
surtout c'est pas ça on en revient où on
en était quand on en était à l'époque
des alliés bertrand il ya dix ans l'om
est justement considéré que la france
était le pays européen le mieux s'armer
justement parce qu'on avait ses stocks
donc si vous voulez nous le problème de
la france c'est pas tellement de nous
comparer avec les autres aujourd'hui
c'est de nous comparer par rapport à
nous mêmes on était on était les
meilleurs si vous voulez on était les
plus protégés et à la fin on est devenu
comme les autres c'est à dire
complètement vulnérables et démunis mais
le problème c'est pas par rapport aux
autres c'est par rapport à ce qu'on
avait au départ car des réactions et
commentaires
quelqu'un disait finalement ces dates de
péremption est ce que c'est pas l'idée
de l'obsolescence programmée
c'est ce qu'on dit souvent le dire
vendra les industriels ils vont mettre
une date de péremption parce que
justement ça permet de dire bah ça c'est
plus utile faut que j'en produis d'un
autre puisque c'est l'une des hypothèses
que vous avez pu constater de se dire
que les industriels finalement profite
peut-être un peu de s'admettre détention
sur des outils ou n'aura pas forcément
besoin on a joué comme quoi peut-être
qu'on n'a même pas l'esprit assez mal
placé pour annoncer à sa honnêtement moi
je suis un peu peut-être je suis un peu
naïf moi ce que j'avais ce que
l'explication qu'on nous a donnée en
tout cas moi je peux dire ce qu'on nous
a données c'était la peur des
industriels d'être attaqués au motif
qu'ils auraient un incident donc
principe de précaution ultime mais c'est
une question intéressante très
pertinente effectivement on peut pas
exclure que évidemment si on met une
date de péremption ça veut dire faut
renouveler et donc fort en racheter
c'est une possibilité qu'on n'a pas
intérêt à 9 heures on s'est procuré les
contrats entre l'état et les entreprises
entre autres bacou dalloz et dont il y
avait un article dans ce contrat le onze
je crois qu'ils disaient crée clairement
à partir du moment où les masques seront
jugés périmés tous les ff les deux voilà
on recommencera le processus de
production pour abonder à nouveau les
stocks c'était prévu donc ça c'était
vraiment quelque 2000
c'est sous la vie bertrand c'est la fin
c'est la fin des années 2000 ne pâtit
suivi du trait le contrat n'a pas été
renouvelé
voilà qui s'est arrêté il est mort de sa
belle mort donc l année une liste
arrêtée à la fin duquel s'étaient
soulevés bertrand donc à une dizaine
d'années
willm lors du quinquennat nicolas
sarkozy quelques réactions quand les
commentaires marianne alors peut-être
une question un peu technique est ce que
toutes ces enquêtes prévus seront menées
si une loi est votée pour l'impunité des
politiques concernant la pandémie on
n'en est pas là
non non on n'en est pas là d'abord je
j'imagine assez peu qu'une loi sur la
nappe unités soit votée ça se passe
d'être des gens réagissent ou l'immunité
départ positif c'est pas la même chose
pas la même chose les ministres sont
devront répondre
après ça il ya une structure assez pour
le coup va c'est obsolète qui s'appelle
la cour de justice de la république qui
est chargé de juger les ministres pour
les actes commis durant l'exercice de
leur mandat ministériel et ça encore en
piscine pour pouvoir qu'il soit jugé il
faut passer par plusieurs filtres donc
les plaintes qui sont déposées à la cour
du lycée la république il va falloir des
années avant qu'elle arrive à être même
quasiment instruite quoi donc
en revanche il ya des plaintes qui sont
déposées au parquet de paris
donc matière pénale et s'est plainte là
ça ira plus vite il y aura une enquête
préliminaire qui seront ordonnés géré
par paquets paris et du coup là il y
aura des policiers qui seront affectés à
ça et ça va bouger c'est une certitude
et enfin il y aura il n'y aura pas
d'impunité qui vaille est ensuite ni
d'immunité parce que ici il ya vraiment
des problèmes qui se posent et il suffit
de demander la levée l'immunité
et enfin enfin il veillera il y aura des
enquêtes parlementaires et c'est encore
ce qui est le plus important parce que
ça va aller encore plus vite c'est celle
d enquête parlementaire ça va arriver là
et très vite voilà deux en espérant un
temps plus calme
le sun le sénat a annoncé qu'ils
feraient la sienne dès le mois de juin
et après avoir un bras de fer peut-être
politique au niveau de l'assemblée
nationale et qui pour l'instant ont
conduit une mission d'information et
l'opposition notamment de droite
voudrait que ce soit une commission
denquête en tous les cas il y aura il y
aura au moins deux enquêtes
parlementaires etc il y aura des
explications à donner cette fois donc
les enquêtes donc d'un point judiciaires
et parlementaires c'est important
d'évoquer parce que beaucoup possèdent
question justement de la suite et donc
ses enquêtes parlementaires peuvent se
dérouler même en période
on va dire de restrictions comme celle
qu'on vienne m c'est ce qui se passera
il y aura des auditions par
visioconférence si besoin ils vont
lister tous les administratifs qui ruent
à gérer ces histoires là ils vont lister
tous les députés tous les rapporteurs de
l'eau à tous les ministres tous les
directeurs de la santé et ils vont tous
les interviewés et interviewé je
reprends le terme ils vont toucher
interrogé de manière assez assez
efficace il faut se souvenir de ce qui
se passe dans les différentes
commissions d enquête précédente
ça va ça peut aller très loin ils ont
peuvent avoir des vrais pouvoirs enquête
les parlementaires en france 1
et du coup sachant que le cedar
l'occurrence n'est pas favorable à la
macro ni ils peuvent être très très très
offensif sur le sujet donc c'est vrai
qu'il faut surveiller de très près la
commission enquête aux saisons qu'on
l'avait vu à l'époque comme la
commission enquête par rapport à la
sphère bénin la wii ou à l'assemblée
c'était parfois un peu plus calmes et au
sénat c'était bien là c'est différent
parce que benalla c'était c'était plutôt
l'erreur d'un homme ce était plutôt ce
qui s'est construit autour d'un énorme
on l'avait d'ailleurs les enquêtes
judiciaires n'ont pas donné suite
par ap visant les différents
intervenants à l'elysée steve une
affaire importante mais c'était c'était
plutôt l'erreur d'un homme et on voit
bien qu'ils ont eu du mal à trouver
d'autres problèmes là il ya quand même
beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de lieux vous
allez chercher les informations
la différence c'est que dans cette
affaire la même par rapport à plein
d'autres
c'est que c'est une affaire qui concerne
tout le monde voilà tout le monde se
reconnaît t da et d'ailleurs il ya
beaucoup de victimes et des beaucoup
pour ça que autant de plaintes de partie
civile de gens qui disent mais moi moi
personnellement en tant que citoyen les
erreurs de l'état
j'en ai été la victime ce sera à la
justice de dire s'ils ont raison de
penser ça mais on peut comprendre qu'ils
pensent ça il ya des gens qui n'ont pas
été protégés qui ont été contaminés bah
oui mais est-ce que l'état n'est pas en
faute c'est plus qu'une question qui
sont les commentaires on compte quelque
chose avant de conclure cela il ya cette
question justement qu'il dit qui signe
les contrats de renouvellement vous
évoqué précédemment les contraindront le
bilan de masse c'est le directeur jean
la santé ministre bah là en l'occurrence
ce contrat dont on parle je me souviens
très bien qu'on a trouvé une lettre de
2002 villepin qui était premier ministre
à l'époque et qui qui qui avait été
alertée par les industriels qui disait
ça va pas assez vite ça ne va pas assez
vite l'état et met trop de temps la
ministre se met trop de temps à faire
bouger les choses et nous étions poste
demi
5 j'ai pu la présidente est monté il
était premier ministre en 2005 donc ça
se retrouvent leur canne allemand et
donc du coup ils ont dominé lille pas
avait incité dans une lettre très
officielle qu'on va retrouver l'état
donc ses subalternes c'est à dire au
ministère de la santé dgs aller encore
plus vite dans la commande est donc
c'est ce qui s'est passé il y avait
vraiment une sorte d'urgence sanitaire à
l'époque et ensuite le contrat comme
tout contrat ils sont ils sont prévus
pour un certain nombre d'années et quand
au bout d'un moment il faut renouveler
il ya eu un nouvel appel d'offres
l'entreprise en l'occurrence s'appelle
bacou-dalloz cette entreprise l'appel
d'offres elle a été jugée
sa réponse a été jugée hors délai non
les souvenirs je crois et donc du coup
elle n'a pas été la commande n'a pas été
renouvelé et et dans tous les cas il
faut rappeler que il ya un moment un
petit peu plus tard les appels d'offres
ne seront plus jamais renouvelée parce
qu'une grande partie d'entre eux
portaient sur donc les fameux masques
ffp2 destinés aux professionnels et
comme on l'a expliqué la nouvelle
doctrine a été de dire les ffp2 ce n'est
plus à l'état de les commander donc par
définition les entreprises qui viennent
nous réclamer des commandos masqués
basse est allé voir les hôpitaux
allez voir les samuël aller voir les
épaves et sauf que les ehpad et hôpitaux
etc il n'avait pas l'argent pour
commander et ça a été le début du
délitement question martin qui dans les
commentaires s'intéressent un peu au
travail d'investigation et qui dit
combien de temps ça prend pour réaliser
ce type d' enquête entre nous en vous
vous avez les premières informations et
la publication ces indigents dans
journal le monde on a en fait on a été
alerté sur tout ça on a fait un long
portrait de roselyne bachelot dont le
monde dans lequel on la rencontrait très
longuement et à nous expliquer ce qui
s'était passé à son époque et on s'est
dit il ya quand même un truc qui se
passe quoi voilà et ça c'était mi mars
quoi à peu près juste après le
confinement et donc du coup c'est à
partir de ce moment là qu'on a commencé
à se mettre là dessus on l'a proposé au
monde le monde nous a dit vous allez
tout là parce que vous voulez allez-y
foncez vous avez tout le temps il a pas
ce que vous voulez et donc on a mis un
mois à enquêter aller voir les gens
compliqué en paille de confinement donc
on était beaucoup de skype mais il faut
aller voir les gens quand même parce que
pour obtenir des documents ils voulaient
donc pas par skype donc il fallait les
voir les gens de visu et c'est dans les
ministères et à droite à gauche et il
finit un mois pour la réaliser cette
enquête et
une semaine pour l'écrire ce qui est un
délai très très court pour une enquête
qui fait 140 mille signes c'est long
c'est presque un demi livre quoi donc du
coup son n'a pas chômé on n'a pas chômé
mais il nous a manqué des choses
l'enquète et les longues et complète
mais il nous manque des éléments c'est
la célébration en état sont il faut il
faut admettre que le journalisme c'est
quelque chose d'un parfait on est
toujours frustré parce que on pourra
toujours faire mieux on pourra toujours
faire plus nous on n'a pas fait dans
quel parfaite on a fait une enquête que
j'estime je pense complète mais parfaite
non la preuve on reçoit plein de mails
d'un formateur en fait qui nous qui nous
envoient des nouveaux documents des
nouveaux rapports on se dit abazid si on
a eu si on avait su ça on aurait ajouté
ça etc
mais après on n'en finit jamais il faut
au moins avoir donné une vision à peu
près complète de la situation je pense
que c'est le cas
mais je pense par contre il ya toujours
de quoi enquêter investiguer il ya
d'autres médias qui ont pris le relais
d'ailleurs après et c'est très bien il
faut que chacun s'y mêlent parce que
honnêtement il ya c'est ça comment
dirais-je et les ja vous saviez un peu
un cliché dans la profession qui pour
dire les gens les gens ont le droit de
savoir
mais c'est pas du poujadisme là pour le
coup je pense que c'est c'est la moindre
des choses qu'on sache qui s'est passé
avec ses stocks de masques dont on avait
besoin et qui ont été choriste et
détruit de manière incroyable alors vous
connaît justement journée
d'investigation c'est à dire ce qu'est
ce que des fois il ya des gens qui vous
on voit des éléments comme ça qu'ils
disent ah bah tiens moi j'ai des choses
à vouloir révéler suis scandalisé par sa
fin des lanceurs d'alerté quelque part
qui vont vous envoyez un mail avec des
éléments ça arrive des fois ça on en a
il faut bien admettre que ce ne sont pas
toujours des informations de première
main qui sont vraiment d'intérêt général
ce sont souvent des intérêts
particuliers
on les respecte mais on n'a pas vocation
à enquêter dessus reçoit d'autres
éléments auxquels on devrait prêter plus
d'attention parfois et qu'on ne fait pas
parce qu'on est pris sur autre chose et
on en reçoit qui sont intéressants sur
laquelle on travaille donc c'est assez
valable ça assez variable en fait mais
on a un gros défaut que je considère
comme étant un gros avantage aussi c'est
qu'on n'est pas surtout sur les réseaux
sociaux écrit ce n'est pas sur twitter
on n'est pas sur grand chose en fait ni
sur facebook ni autre chose et ça nous
coupe vous il est en ce moment on sera
ravi mais ça nous coupe justement de pas
mal de réseaux d'informations qui
pourraient pas venir à nous mais ça nous
évite aussi de
de nous quereller parfois et des gens
qui seraient pas forcément d'accord avec
tout ce qu'on dit mot et puis on se dit
que les gens qui veulent nous envoyer
des informations ont les moyens de le
joindre on a un site internet il nous
adresse email du monde sont connus par
tout le monde et on est facile à trouver
ça pourrait qu'elle soit 6 du
journaliste d'investigation c'est à leur
tête d'un point de vue global je pense
que c'était intéressant de peut-être
congé un peu d'aidé là dessus c'est de
se dire parfois quand des gens vous
envoie des éléments il peut y avoir un
intérêt personnel derrière on peut
parfois envoyer des éléments pour
discréditer une personnalité politique
une entreprise autres comment on arrive
à s'extraire de ces de ses possibles
conflits entre personnes qui pourrait
profiter à d'autres et reste vraiment un
travail d'information je ne sais pas
évident non non non mais surtout il faut
et je pense qu'il faut répondre à cette
question de manière transparente faut
pas faux pas faut pas se moquer des gens
en faisant croire que l'on reçoit des
informations qui seraient qui serait
d'une pureté limpide avec derrière aucun
intérêt etc
non c'est faux là il faut plutôt se
partir du postulat inverse toute
personne qui va me parler ou qui va
m'envoyer une information ou même que je
vais solliciter à un intérêt on a tous
un intérêt quand on parle quand on
s'exprime quand on communique donc il
faut déjà être tranquille par rapport à
ça oui bien sûr que chacun a un intérêt
qui peut être louable et qui peut être
je veux dire - moins respectable des
dézinguer un collègue pour prendre sa
place à voir c'est vouloir servir un
intérêt politique au détriment d'un
autre et c'est donc comment faire par
rapport à ça et ben si on part du
principe que de toute façon toute
personne a un intérêt quelque part plus
ou moins grand oublions ça et c'est
important de le savoir un il vaut
toujours mieux savoir do i do do me
parle cette personne pourquoi elle a
fait ça ok mais après il ya qui le
comment dirais-je le seul fil conducteur
de nos enquêtes c'est la véracité des
informations c'est à dire c'est parce
que la personne me dit elle imite ce que
me disent comme dit la personne
j'aime bien macron chaîne pas macron se
suit celui ci a fait ça et c'est ok les
gens parlent ça c'est ils ont le droit
mais c'est ça c'est pas ça qui va nous
intéresser
qu'est ce que vous avez comme faits
précis à nous donner vous avez un
document vous avez une information
précise que je peux recouper et là après
après le fait de savoir si la personne
me donne un rapport par exemple où on a
publié dans dans notre série d'articles
des rapports confidentiels
le fait de savoir si la personne qui me
donne un rapport confidentiel et les
ailes et elle est proche de tel ou
proche de tel sincèrement ça devient
secondaire parce que si j'entre dans
cette logique là je ne prends plus aucun
rapport que toute personne a un intérêt
par contre ce qui va m'intéresser c'est
d'utiliser le rapport de le lire moi
même avec ma grille de lecture
et ne pas être influencé par la personne
qui va me dire alors voyez vous est
donné ce rapport reprenait bien ce qui
marche et prisca marqué page 37 mais ne
lisait pas avant c'est pas intéressant
non ça c'est qu'on n'achète pas donc
voilà donc ne pas se prendre trop la
traite dans l'idée qu'il y ait des gens
auraient un intérêt tout le monde a un
intérêt par contre se concentrer sur les
faits les faits rien que les faits
ce qui est amusant d'ailleurs c'est que
quand on a produit notre premier article
nous tient dix derniers le 4 mai je
crois j'ai commencé à lire un petit peu
les réactions des lecteurs du monde et
il ya les certains cette transaction
était à avec da vélum à nouveau ça va
taper sur sarkozy
forcément le coupable sera sarkozy or si
on conduit continue la liste des
enquêtes qu'on a fait depuis les cinq 5
jours suivants on s'aperçoit que
justement réhabilite plus tôt l'action
des ministres sarkozystes
donc c'est pour mener pour dire qu'il
n'ya pas d'intérêt de l'autre côté a
agonisé d'injures ou de faits
désagréables telle ou telle majorité
politique les faits rien que les faits
juste effet la question des pressions
aussi c'est ce qu'on pense souvent quand
on parle de joris d'investigation c'est
que justement parfois vous révéler des
choses qui vont on va dire d'un point et
politiques peuvent être détrôné carrière
mais des industries ou autre comment on
arrive à éviter ça parce que quelque
part vers des pressions de pour que nous
puissions publier quelque chose d'autre
oui on s'en détache alors les pressions
d'abord c'est exact je suis très tenté
de faire la même réponse que par rapport
au sens qu'il voudrait nous manipuler
les pressions elles sont consubstantiels
notre métier
surtout quand on est journaliste
d'investigation ou d' enquête on est là
pour pour gratter là où ça fait mal on
est à pour on est un peu des emmerdeurs
tous les journalistes enquêtent c'est
normal même si vous faites pas
exactement mobility dont quelques nous
mais pas exactement en aurons deux roues
qu'on embête un peu les gens voient là
parce qu'on révèle des choses ça les
dérange et c'est donc déjà si on veut
pas avoir de pression ont fait un autre
métier y en a plein d'autres où on
oublie ce métier là et deuxièmement on
n'aime pas trop parler de ça nous
concernant parce que nous on est un
grand journal qui fait qu'on a des
procès par exemple il ya des avocats qui
sont pris en charge par le
financièrement par le journal qui vont
nous défendre koné des pleins c'est
exactement le dédier un pas vers mon
exact enfin c'est vers vincent oui mais
on est on est sécuriser juridiquement on
a des avocats excellent par ailleurs
évidemment pour un grand journal comme
ça c'est normal
pareil quand on fait des livres avec une
grande maison d'édition comme fayard on
et protéger les journalistes
indépendants déjà c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué pour eux de résister ou de
subir ces pressions ça c'est la première
chose
la seconde chose c'est qu'il faut faire
preuve de décence moi j'ai dit combien
preuve de décence on vit en france on
travaille en france
en france on n'assassine pas les
journalistes et moi je me vois mal me
point me plaindre aujourd'hui pour dire
on m'embête on a fait un procès on a été
menacé de mort etc
quand on pense à ce que font les
journalistes à malte les journalistes en
russie les jeux en corée du nord vous
pouvez prendre tous les pc monde en
chine
honnêtement je dis pas que tout est
parfait s'étaient pas doutées rossa et
jeudi il faut parfois relativiser nos
récriminations anneaux complainte c'est
un peu plus des coûts auxquels on l'a vu
par exemple avec ariane chemin
oui il travaille au monde qui avait été
convoqué par la wii mais j'ai essayé du
togo n'a été plaqué nouvelle disclose
également btp deux ans avant par la dgsi
aussi et travaille sur une affaire sur
un document confidentiel défense qu'on
était sortis ces défense nationale
secret défense qu'on avait sorti dans le
monde
on avait été convoqué par la dgs ivg ci
fait son boulot c'est se terminer par un
rappel à la loi
si vous voulez honnêtement moi je suis
comme fabrice un peu de décence c'est
pas grave d'être convoqué à la dgsi ils
font leur boulot et nous on dit secret
des sources et en général ça s'arrête là
on n'est pas placé en garde et voilà on
est pas il ya pas de garde à vue enfin
c'est peut-être pas très
politiquement correct de dire ça mais
moi je ils font leur boulot quoi il est
policier et l'état fait son boulot mais
si on découpe carrée aussi nos
incursions dans leur travail et nous on
fait notre boulot protéger les sources
et ça c'est un soucis récents sa
protection et l'essentiel et on va sa
ration en france et 2 et les dernières
choses importantes aussi qui est
consubstantielle à la pression c'est
qu'on travaille au monde leur monde
on a cette chance d'avoir un grand
joueur qui nous protège et également
d'avoir une indépendance et une zéro
pression quand on nous a demandé
d'enquêter et qu'on leur a proposées
d'enquêter sur ça il aurait pu dire le
pouvoir aurait pu dire même les
actionnaires auraient pu dire on aurait
pu dire quoi que ce soit mais vous allez
tailler des noises à emmanuel macron etc
la vérité c'est que ces personnes ne
nous dit rien du moment que les faits
sont les faits on publie ce qu'on veut
au monde une indépendance totale et ça
c'est génial et on est violent qui a
revendiqué et il est il courant de faire
appel aux renseignements afin de
commencer les enquêtes journalistiques
ap le renseignement c'est à dire
cervidés ces maçons ont fait par appel
vous fait pas appel nous on va les voir
on va dire qu'on va voir tout le monde
de a à z du fonctionnaire de base du de
la préfecture au patron des services de
renseignement on va voir absolument tout
le monde sait ce qu'on appelle aller
chercher l'information aller chercher
des sources et ensuite on obtient des
informations et ces informations là où
les vérifierons les contextualise donc
c'est ça c'est rien de scandaleux c'est
le travail de journaliste mais c'est pas
facile parce qu'il faut bien comprendre
qu'on va voir des gens qui
officiellement souvent n'ont pas droit
de parler donc après c'est la difficulté
du métier et aussi son intérêt c'est
comment je vais convaincre qu'une
personne qui a des informations
intéressantes de par son poste à me
faire confiance
alors que il peut se mettre en risque
par rapport à sa hiérarchie etc et d'où
l'importance du secret des sources a
c'est vraiment ça très chez nous c'est
qu'une personne qui nous donnent des
informations en échange on la protège
quoi qu'il arrive et jamais son identité
ne sera et le doigté faits révélés ça
c'est un fondement sacré du journalisme
pour conclure cela est peut-être un peu
une question vers de se dire qu'est ce
que vous avez ressenti à travers cette
enquête j'ai en cinq parties c'est quoi
le ressenti que vous avez sur la gestion
de cette crise sanitaire sur le gestion
politique qui nous parlent pas forcément
50 de ce quinquennat là mais de ces
vingt dernières années vu que c'est une
enquête aussi au long cours qui part du
début des années 2000 jusqu'à 2020 au
revoir on peut répondre chacun mais moi
je j'y vois deux choses intéressantes
c'est
le rôle du politique je leur aie évalue
à cette enquête c'est à dire que le
politique a un rôle essentiel en france
c'est lui qui a impulsé une politique
administrative ensuite on voit bien
qu'elle compte des directives claires et
volontaristes sont donnés sur le plan
politique l'administration suis derrière
même s'il met du temps et donc du coup
quelque chose se crée et c'est ce qu'on
a vu sous bachelot sous bertrand et
c'est donc ça pour moi ça me paraît
essentiel est le deuxième aspect c'est
que je pense qu'effectivement il ya dans
cette histoire tous les ressorts n'en
déplaise à monsieur guérini il ya tous
les ressorts d'un scandale parce que
parce que c'est une crise sanitaire
évidemment sans précédent et que la
france s'est retrouvé démuni au elle
avait besoin de la protection de l'état
voyez moi justement pour rebondir là
dessus moi ce qui m'a ce qui m'a frappé
c'est que je sais qu'on est parti dans
cette enquête alors vraiment pour le
coup sans aucun a priori pour une bonne
raison c'est qu'on ne connaissait rien à
rien on n'était pas notre secteur est
grand plus n'avait pas de source donc on
n'avait pas d'à priori et même tu me
rappelle très bien avec gérard on s'est
dit au début bon bah on va essayer de
faire quelque chose de sérieux pour le
journal le monde que c'est un journal
sérieux avec du recul etc
mais faut être honnête sur cette enquête
là pour le coup on va papa
ça va pas faire scandale on va pas on va
pas trouver de secret d'état on va pas
pas faire trembler la république on va
voilà on n'est pas dans l'investigation
comme on peut le l'arrivée où ils
imaginent et parfois de manière
caricaturale on s'est dit on va faire un
truc plutôt très sérieux très très
rigoureux sur la politique sanitaire de
la france est en fait on s'est vraiment
c'est pas nous qui l'avons cherché mais
on s'est aperçu qu'en fait ce qu'on
mettait au jour
oui ça tout bêtement je vois pas comment
on peut l'appeler autrement ça les
ingrédients d'un scandale d'état
quand on explique comment sciemment
l'état s'est désarmé et on est venu à
détruire des stocks qui était valable et
qui pouvait sauver des vies je vois pas
comment on appelle ça autrement une
enquête donc en cinq points a retrouvé
donc dans les colonnes du monde et aussi
donc en replay dans ce facebook live on
a abordé donc jeudi pour ceux qui
viennent nous rejoindre vous retrouver
dans quelques instants
le rip et facebook live où on a abordé
donc toutes ces questions sur 20 ans de
gestion sanitaire sur la question des
masques et un peu élargie à à une
réflexion globale parce qu'il ya la
question des masques mais ça ça touche
aussi d'autres sujets dans la gestion de
cette crise sanitaire donc ça vous
pouvez le revoir
henry pendant quelques instants dans les
colonnes du journal du monde sait ce que
je vous disais et puis également on
l'avait rencontré aussi edwy plenel qui
avait sorti cette enquête sur le fiasco
des masques
on avait on avait fait un live aussi
avec lui de cela un mois vous pouvez
retrouver également en replay sur notre
page facebook et son compte youtube une
enquête que vous avez été très nombreux
à lire sur mediapart mais aussi dans le
facebook live qu'on avait pu faire et
c'est aussi encore archives et donc
comme l'ensemble de nos direct vous
pouvez toujours retrouver l'intégralité
shekels certaines personnes qui voient
là j'arrive en cours de l'acte que bon
je fais pour voir ce qu'on a évoqué
précédemment bien toujours en replay
cette vidéo dans quelques instants quand
on voit la conclure vous rafraîchissez
la page et vous pouvez retrouver
directement l'intégralité en replay
c'est également en replay sur twitter
live donc ce sont deux constructeurs but
officiel et probablement dans les
prochaines heures sur notre chaîne
youtube brut officiel également sur
lequel vous pouvez retrouvez également
beaucoup de documentaires très
intéressant sur notre chaîne youtube
merci à vous merci merci merci gérard
davet merci fabrice lhomme rappelle un
grand reporter au monde pour cet
entretien et on rappelle donc en replay
tout de suite très bonne journée à tous
ceux qui nous ont suivis et très bonne
journée aujourd'hui